vous pourrez faire demain matin une
grasse matinée exceptionnelle l'heure
d'hiver prendra effet la nuit prochaine
à 3 heures et si j'ose dire à 3 heures
il sera 2 heures je vous conseille donc
dès à présent de retarder vos montres
d'une heure et vos réveils également une
mesure qui permet vous le savez
d'économiser 300 mille tonnes de pétrole
mais le problème subsiste les européens
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord pour
adopter la même heure michel chevalet
le changement d'heure s'est un peu la
logique du temps retrouvé d'un tank
l'homme conserve dans les rouages de ses
pendules d'un temps qu'ils adaptent
aujourd'hui au rythme des saisons comme
le soleil se lève plus tard en automne
nous nous lèverons une heure plus tard
dès demain matin en effet cette nuit à 3
heures du matin il ne sera
officiellement que deux heures mais
cette petite heure gagnée chaque jour
sur les ténèbres fait qu'aujourd'hui
en un an nous consommons moins d'énergie
pour nous éclairer
trois cent mille tonnes d'équivalent
pétrole disent les spécialistes soit en
un an
le chauffage d'une ville de cinq cent
mille habitants ce changement d'heure
sera reconduit l'année prochaine mais
hélas pas au même moment dans toute
l'europe principal obstacle
l'allemagne qui refuse toujours de jouer
le jeu entraînant dans son sillage la
suisse quant à l'angleterre
elles gardent ce prétexte pour continuer
à appliquer son heure d'été sur une
période plus longue de fait
l'imbroglio des horaires des trains et
des avions internationaux va continuer
encore l'année prochaine et jusqu'en
1981 l'orbe de l'heure n'est pas encore
né une tempête dans un verre d'eau
certes qui occupe bien des experts à
bruxelles mais laissent indifférents
ceux qui savent encore vivre de l'air du
temps
[Musique]